today I'm going to talk about Auto  healing managed instance groups  occasionally a bug or other error might  cause one of your instances to get into  a bad state with Auto healing instance  groups VMs that aren't functioning  correctly are detected and recreated so  that you always have the correct number  of healthy instances I have an instance  group setup and I want to add a health  check to it so I can use auto healing I  click on the instance group name and  then I click Edit group now I scroll  down to the auto healing and health  check section I create a new health  check and give it a name I'm gonna check  on port 80 with HTTP on the base path I  want to check every 60 seconds and if  there are three unhealthy checks in a  row I want to recreate the instance now  I click Save and continue  and click Save and that's it my managed  instance group is Auto healing now I  hope you found this cloud minute helpful